oh yeah thank you bro
Los Angeles California central was not
my dad just my mother my grandmother I
had an abusive childhood I was abused by
my brother a lot he beat me up too he
beat me unconscious one time I was in
the hospital for two days for that he
was very like I read without through his
life he had a lot of growing up bad
things half of him
so reflected on us he took his anger and
abuse I don't know my mom we didn't step
in and protect me I was raised in a
Christian home so it was more so that
whatever happened to you just let God
forgive them for it and gotta take care
of the problem it was more so that it
never really wasn't no you know let's
get the police involved or anything like
that but my brother beat me for years
yeah
older so we got older the last time I'm
39 so the last time he put his hands on
me I was 24 and yeah it continued for a
while I had a baby brother that was
abusive also and one time I was driving
I was at church just happened at church
and they got upset because I thought
they want to use my car to go to Marina
Valley and I wouldn't allow them use my
car so my baby brother jumped on me and
he tried to beat me up and it happened
at church and I ended up taking my car
and I try to run away but the car and
they're out of control and it almost hit
my brother Nemo's died I think a lot of
their anger and frustration came from my
father my father was abusive towards my
mother he beat her for 11 years - one
time that she was blind for like four
days so I think it came from our father
sort of speak he wasn't he was in and
out of my life for a while the last time
I talked and spoken with my father when
he found out what happened it was after
me getting raped by my cousin
I read by my first cousin by the name of
Jean Taylor he raped me when I was 15
years old he molested me for like four
years then he raped me after that so he
was molested me when I was a child
yeah he was molested when I was a child
and my parents my mother believed the
story but my ex he didn't believe the
story which was his mother she passed
away by him he drowned his mother no
eating he caught they just didn't see it
as a drowning they'd seen it was trying
to help her so he's been running for
some years but they didn't see it as
that I don't really speak with my family
every now and he and I have a sister I
go to church with I speak with her from
time to time but I don't really talk to
my family like that we don't really have
a connection like that I went out on my
own at the age of 18 and then I went to
CCC counts for a Conservation Corps and
then I have ran into this lady by the
name Andre Johnson she and to become my
godmother and then I was on my own with
her for a while and then I ventured off
because I ended up being their lesbian
and I was in a relationship with this
girl so my family was always against my
homosexual lifestyle and that's where a
lot of abuse came from too because they
didn't want me to be gay they felt their
putting hands on me or you know speaking
to me some type of way that it was gonna
change the fact of who I was and who I
am which that doesn't have that that's
not gonna work
so they judge me a lot so I was on my
own for a while and then I ended up
moving in with my first girlfriend and
we were together for like five years it
was a cool relationship but it was a lot
of abuse too and neglect in that
relationship because I found myself
doing and repeating the same cycle
putting my hands on her I was fighting
her a lot so but it came from a lot of
hurt and pain abuse from my childhood
and then at the age of 26 27 I end up
going to jail then I end up going to
prison and I did my time in prison I was
in prison for a couple years and then I
got out on parole and
paroled I came down here to skid row and
I stayed at the Winegard and then I was
on at UM at the Weingard like a couple
of months before I became on Skid Row
and then I was like in and out so I just
got a prison not so long ago I did
another prison turn I just got a prison
not too long ago on May 4th I was
released this year so I've been like
living here and there and here and there
I was my first term was a terrorist
threat it was assault on a police
officer I end up put my hands on a cop I
fought the police and then my second
term was granted so you're living on the
street now yes I used crystal I've been
on crystal for like two years
no I wasn't and then it was pills I was
used to taking pharmaceutical drugs
which is pills I was on pills for like
nine years taking mirko's and summers to
take away my pain or just numb me to the
fact that what's going on in my life you
know not having a father being there for
me and me and my mother not having a
real close connection you know I was
doing that for a while I overdosed one
time in my house my neighbor came and
she found me and I was or I had
overdosed from the pills that I was
taking so that kind of to kind of lure
me to like trying to like stop me from
taking them but I haven't really stopped
taking them I take them every now and
then
and we use money now
well I'm not working at this per current
moment I'm temp agency so I'm trying to
get work to them but I'm not really
employee right now selling drugs what I
used to do when I wasn't working out for
our people before that was my making my
wheels and making my means and making
money it was one time I even arrived
this neighborhood wean store I robbed
them up did a lot I did fake checks fake
I didn't boss I didn't he
I didn't eat them I've did that to
trying to make it it's hard out here
you're welcome
thank you okay how are you